bueno en principio los reclamos son una
lista de 10 puntos que han presentado
los dirigentes indígenas básicamente lo
que piden es una reiteración de lo que
habían sido los reclamos de las
protestas del año 2019 que continúa
inclusive el día de hoy básicamente lo
que están pidiendo es el congelamiento
del precio de los combustibles ellos
demandan que el precio del diésel se
fije en 1.50 dólares en este momento se
me tienen uno con un 90 y en la gasolina
en 2 con 10 en este momento la gas
unidad se mantiene en 255 en su versión
más económica o extra hoy aborde algo
casi los 5 dólares en su versión super
es una de las principales demandas que
hacen de igual forma ellos le piden
crear una política de control de precios
porque luego de la creado este sistema
de bandas de instalación de los precios
medios denuncia que hay una especie de
especulación de los distintos
subproductos tanto de la cesta básica
como especialmente de los productos del
agro recordemos que las organizaciones
indígenas se dedican principalmente a la
producción de la tierra y de igual forma
ellos han pedido que se revise se
ejecute una moratoria de créditos de un
año para las distintas deudas entre una
de las listas que mantienen y reiteran a
partir del día de hoy también